Marc Scott Zicree, Screenwriter/Author: But
ultimately for any film or tv show or book
or any work of art, to have relevance, it has to
touch you here. It has to move you emotionally.
We love Van Gogh not because
of the theory of what he's
doing. We love Van Gogh because those
paintings speak to us, they move us.
Film Courage: What do you love
about Star Trek Discovery?
Marc: Doug Jones I think is terrific. He's the
lead in Space Command as well (or one of our lead
actors) and he's absolutely wonderful. I think the
production design is pretty amazing. I think the
detail on sets and costumes is pretty amazing,
the visual effects are good. I think it's gone
kind of…I haven't watched all of the third season
yet but I felt the first couple of seasons were
pretty weak in terms of just characterization and
story line. There's a lot of talent in that cast
but I would have developed the characters very
differently. I would have gone much deeper. I
think that there's a very hit-and-miss quality to
a number of the characters where it's like who are
these people? What what's the point of this story?
I think they're often talking about the emotion
without actually dramatizing the emotion and so
A Strange New World's maybe the Star Trek episode
the show we're all waiting for that's the ones
captain pike the fun part about that is captain
pike was the original captain the first pilot
that Gene Roddenberry did of Star Trek in 1964.
and so if that and now that's being greenlit as
a show so it's the longest period for when a show
was pitched when a pilot was made to when they
actually picked up the show it's like 55 years or
60 years that's pretty fun how do you think gene
roddenberry would have felt about Star Trek today
I think he would be have very mixed feelings
I think he'd be very glad that was still
generating billions of dollars and
still popular I think I don't think
he would necessarily be that fond of Star
Trek discovery or picard simply because
they are missing the opportunity
of telling stories that have
relevance to the current moment you know I think
he was very very much someone who wanted to
make emotional points that related to the
real world and I think Star Trek discovery and
picard have been they kind of have sort of they're
kind of drifting a little bit you know and it so
I don't think he'd necessarily like those shows
particularly but that's not for me to say you know
ask him when they clone him you know what's your
argument that Star Trek is better than star wars
well my argument is I wouldn't say that Star
Trek is better than star wars I would just
say that it's different I you know it's my friend
mel gilden says the golden age of science fiction
is 13. and of course by that he means that when
you're a 13 year old that's when you find those
things in science fiction that really speak to
your heart and the universes you want to live in
it's just for me I remember when I was a kid I
recorded the original broadcast of Star Trek on
reel-to-reel tape in case the show never aired
again and there were no vcrs there's no way to
you know record the entire show where you could
watch it but I remember that week after week
after week there were stories that i'd never seen
anywhere before they were astonishing and they
had such profound meaning for my life you know
I remember a city on the edge of forever where
kirk and spock and mccoy go back to the 30s and
kirk falls in love with this woman who runs a soup
kitchen and ultimately he finds out that in order
for the time flow of time to turn out correctly
she has to die and so he literally allows her
to be hit by a truck he throws her into a truck
and every tv show i'd ever seen before that the
hero saved the girl it was just a given and in
this one he's responsible for the death of the
girl and and the message was sometime in your life
there'll be something you know is the right thing
to do but it'll break your heart but because it's
the right thing to do you have to do it and I was
profoundly changed by that one episode that harlan
ellison wrote and and I and and so Star Trek
had a deep deep formative influence on me and
whereas I can't say that luke or leia or obi-wan
or any of those characters as much as I like them
changed me in any way particularly other
than entertaining me for a few hours
so so I'm not I think if someone thinks that star
wars is better than Star Trek more power to them
I think it's fine for anyone to have any opinion
basically as long as it doesn't hurt anyone
you know I think compassion has to be what rules
us and it's it's so liberating when you don't need
to be right you know when you say this is just my
opinion if you have a different opinion it's fine
that does of course that doesn't mean racism or
misogyny or any of those things you have to speak
out against things that are really hurting people
but most opinions are just people having opinions
you know is star wars better than Star Trek I
don't know not for me but for other people sure
it's fine like when jj abrams loves star star
wars you know I mean you know I'm sure that he
feels really bad that he wasn't able to to do
everything he wanted to do with it you know so
luck of the draw it reminds me a little bit of
the keith richards biography where he talked
about a lot of these jazz enthusiasts and
there were two different types there were
the ones that were sort of schooled in
the bars and and had learned to play yes
by ear and then there were others that had
these theories and they would argue it and
the film world feels like that at times yes well
I have I have very little patience with theorists
you know it's funny you know I think of the
twilight zone companion as an oral history of the
twilight zone I was very lucky that all all the
writers directors producers actors were alive with
very few exceptions I mean rod serling was gone
one of the other writers charles bowman was gone
but most everyone else was alive and so I was able
to get the direct story from the people who made
these shows who wrote them and directed and
produced them and the cinematographer and so forth
and but when you have theorists it's like I don't
really want to hear people's theories I don't care
about that it's so academic and so pointless I
would rather hang out with people making something
as opposed to people commenting about something
and it's funny because when I wrote the twilight
zone companion I wrote it to learn how to be a
writer producer in television not and so then when
people offered me gigs to write books about other
tv shows I always said no because that wasn't
why I did that book I didn't do that book to then
write the making of mash or the making of you know
hello kitty or whatever you know any of anything
you know my little pony but you know so I and
and it's funny because on dvds and blu-rays i'll
always listen to the commentaries of the directors
or the writers of the film or tv show but when
it's some guy some theorists like he's the head
of the film department at you know some university
and he has this this theme about alienation or
whatever it's like oh I don't go away you know
it's not it's not worth my time and it's not of
interest to me that doesn't mean that you can't
have larger meanings or metaphors or any of that
but ultimately for any film or tv show or book
or any work of art to have relevance it has to
touch you here it has to move you emotionally we
love van gogh not because of the theory of what
he's doing we love ango because those paintings
speak to us they move us and you know so that's
the one thing I do like about the modern age
is authenticity is valued now so for instance
if people recognize me as an authentic person
and that my work is in alignment with who I
am as a person or the people I mentor the run the
roundtable I run if everything I do from mr sci-fi
to the round table to space command to all these
things are all in a line they all speak to the
same compassions they speak to the same kindness
people recognize that I'm authentic in what I say
and do and I'm very glad that that matters because
when I started my career the only time someone in
the audience would encounter something of some
work of mine is by reading a book i'd written or
watching a tv show I might get a fan letter
or maybe meet someone at a convention now
the audience is directly in communication with me
and I actually like that because it tells me I'm
on the right path because I know and I don't
need the fans I don't need the fans tell me
what to do artistically but it's nice to know that
what I'm setting out to do is being accomplished
so it's great well that's the problem it's people
who are in the ivory tower people who are I mean
particularly like it's like people who didn't
know anyone who made that film or anyone who made
that tv show it's like you know some expert
on howard hawks but he didn't know the guy
and free and frequently they'll come up with
all these reasons why something was done that
has nothing to do with why it was really done it
could be they were losing the light so that's why
he shot it as a one or you know like one with
without cuts you know it might not have been
a stylistic choice and then the light was gone or
you know there's always things that come out great
through the wonderful chaos that production
is you know you always see the love see if
I wanted total control over what I was doing i'd
be a novelist because novelists can sit in their
little rooms and the universe can be exactly
the way they want it in their work and then
they give it to the editor and they can take
those notes or not take those notes but they're
sort of the god of that universe they create I
love to collaborate I love what actors bring in
my work what what designers bring my work what
everyone brings to my work I love collaboration
because there's such an element of surprise if
you choose people who are talented and brilliant
and passionate the work they come up with will
surprise you when an actor takes a for instance
there was a in the pilot of space command there
was a monologue I wrote for bob picardo where he
talks about the death of his wife and when I wrote
it I said this probably won't work but i'll try it
and I can always cut it out and then bob delivered
it and it's astonishing it's wonderful and
and so I was really glad I trusted my actors and
said okay I'm not convinced let me see what he can
do with it and he surprised me because he really
went somewhere truthful and you know and that
was that was me partnering with someone who made
my work better so I have nothing but gratitude.